I want to be appreciative I want to be
thankful
I've been trying to touch myself saying
okay relax chill you know it's not that
important you know it's just very funny
be happy but you know I I didn't have
the chance to talk to many people to to
show my appreciation so what a better
opportunity to do it now and I might get
a little emotional
it's quite an emotional day but I wanna
make I wanna make you understand that
I'm not melancholic at all
I'm fired up with my decision of having
the time I have the decision I made to
have the opportunity to be with these
for so much more time that I want to
make sure that you understand that I'm
not sad at all melancholic I'm very
happy where I am so I want to start
thinking you know without sounding like
a demagogue but first of you all of you
first I mean because as I said in the
video
I can't just an Antonio without knowing
anything about the city carry on full of
doubts and uncertainties we don't know
in what was going to be to play for that
guy to play with that guy to play with
David Robinson or you know anything I
know the facade and I get in the court
and every minute I'm here you guys go
nuts and I you know you start changing
my name and you I felt like you know you
guys had my back you guys wanted me here
so
that would make it forever thankful so
thank you very much